alejándose un poco más del acuerdo
nuclear de 2015 irán planea comenzar a
enriquecer uranio con una pureza del 20
la noticia vino primero del embajador de
rusia de la oea que tuiteó la
información la agencia nuclear lo
confirmó más tarde diciendo que teherán
había informado al organismo de control
de la onu que lo haría en su planta de
fordo para cumplir con la ley aprobada
por el parlamento del país la nueva
norma adoptada el pasado mes en
respuesta al asesinato del mayor
científico nuclear del país box en fuck
risa then llama la producción y el
almacenamiento de al menos 120
kilogramos por año de uranio enriquecido
al 20% la agencia de energía anatómica
del país también dijo al parlamento que
el reactor de agua pesada de arak que
antes debía estar fuera de servicio
podría ser reactivado en menos de 4
meses
aunque se ha dicho que el reactor de
arak se llenó de cemento como dijo el
doctor salehí
está claro que este reactor es revivirlo
según el último informe de la oea
publicado en noviembre irán ya ha
comenzado a alimentar con gas t uranio
las centrifugadoras de enriquecimiento
avanzado en su central subterránea de
natanz no está claro cuándo empezar a
enriquecer uranio al 20% esto todavía
estará lejos del 90% necesario para la
fabricación de una bomba nuclear pero
sería el incumplimiento más importante
del acuerdo de viena por parte de
teherán hasta la fecha ya ha superado el
3 67 por ciento establecido por el
acuerdo en 2019 pero hasta ahora ha
mantenido el nivel por debajo del 4,5
por ciento y ha cumplido con el estricto
régimen de inspección de la oea